se nos pide identificar correctamente en
esta gráfica las áreas de excedente del
consumidor excedente del productor
ingresos fiscales y la pérdida
irrecuperable de eficiencia en este
mercado después de la introducción de un
impuesto pausa el vídeo e intenta
hacerlo sin ayuda incluso si se te
dificulta esto hará que tu cerebro está
en sintonía con nuestro tema muy bien
ahora vamos a resolverlos juntos pero
antes de responder las preguntas lo
primero que necesitamos es entender qué
significa todo este gráfico examinemos
primero las curvas antes de impuestos
antes de impuestos tenemos esta curva de
oferta en azul y esta curva de demanda
en rojo el punto donde se intersectan
nos da el precio de equilibrio aquí y la
cantidad de equilibrio aquí si queremos
saber cuál es el excedente del
consumidor es el área que está arriba de
esta línea horizontal del precio de
equilibrio y debajo de la curva de
demanda este es el excedente del
consumidor antes del impuesto
el excedente del productor antes del
impuesto está arriba de la curva de
oferta y abajo de esta línea horizontal
del precio de equilibrio por lo tanto el
excedente total antes de impuestos es
todo este triángulo pero no se nos está
pidiendo identificar las áreas antes de
impuestos tenemos que identificarlas
después de impuestos entonces qué
hacemos si suponemos que cada unidad que
se ofrece en el mercado tiene un
impuesto el efecto resultante que está
dibujado aquí es que esos impuestos
desplazan hacia arriba la curva de
oferta efectiva recuerden no es que haya
aumentado la oferta al contrario los
oferentes se verán afectados y ofrecen
menos en el mercado y esta nueva curva
de oferta es la que va a afectar el
nuevo precio de equilibrio sin embargo
al momento de analizar los excedentes
nos vamos a encontrar con algunos
matices antes de pensar en ello vamos a
indicar el nuevo precio de equilibrio
con impuestos este es el precio de
equilibrio que ya tiene impuestos la
curva de demanda no se ha desplazado
pero
precio de equilibrio está donde la curva
de demanda se intersecta con la nueva
curva de oferta con impuestos del mismo
modo este punto de intersección también
nos indica la nueva cantidad de
equilibrio con impuestos ahora que ya
todo está claro podemos hablar de los
distintos excedentes la pérdida de
eficiencia en el mercado y los ingresos
fiscales pensemos primero en el
excedente del consumidor el excedente
del consumidor va a ser el área que está
arriba de nuestro precio de equilibrio
horizontal y debajo de la curva de
demanda entonces es esta región r y
recordemos que el excedente del
consumidor es aquello que el consumidor
está dispuesto a pagar pero el precio de
equilibrio está por debajo de esa
exigencia del consumidor vemos aquí a
este consumidor que está dispuesto a
pagar mucho pero aún así paga menos que
esto incluso con impuestos este
consumidor está obteniendo está ganancia
porque habría estado dispuesto a pagar
más que el precio con impuestos así que
está obteniendo este excedente pero vean
que también es una cantidad menor
entonces en estas condiciones del
mercado el excedente total del
consumidor después de impuestos es r r
es igual al excedente del consumidor
después de impuestos vamos a escribirlo
excedente del consumidor
y qué pasa con el excedente del
productor si no tuviéramos que hablar de
impuestos el excedente del productor
sería el área que está arriba de la
curva de oferta y abajo de esta línea de
precio de equilibrio y diríamos que es
el área ese pero recordemos lo que
sucede desde el punto de vista de los
productores ellos no obtienen ingresos
por este nuevo incremento en el precio
recuerda que los productores no se
quedan el ingreso fiscal tienen que
dárselo al gobierno de hecho este es el
precio que ven los productores entonces
esto es lo que obtienen después de
impuestos mejor dicho es lo que obtienen
neto de impuestos creo que es una mejor
manera de decirlo neto de impuestos
entonces el excedente del productor va a
ser el área que está debajo de la línea
de precio a la cual el mercado les
permitiría producir derivado del aumento
del precio y arriba de su curva original
de oferta ya que es lo que estaban
dispuestos a producir así pues el
excedente del productor es esta área que
tiene la be be es igual al excedente del
productor
pasemos ahora a los ingresos fiscales en
esencia los ingresos fiscales van a ser
toda esta otra parte del excedente total
esto es lo que obtiene el gobierno si
los productores no tuvieran que darle
este impuesto al gobierno el gobierno no
podría obtener todo esto entonces el
gobierno va a obtener toda esta área
observa que esta es la cantidad con
impuestos y que el gobierno tiene todo
este beneficio por la cantidad que el
mercado puede intercambiar entre
consumidores y productores derivados del
aumento del precio así que toda esta
área son los ingresos del gobierno
entonces es más o es igual a los
ingresos fiscales
por último qué pasa con la pérdida de
eficiencia en el mercado también llamada
pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia
recuerda que la pérdida de eficiencia es
la diferencia entre el excedente total
antes de impuestos que teníamos cuando
dejamos que el mercado se equilibrará
por sí mismo y el nuevo excedente total
que es más bajo porque el impuesto a los
productores no permite que el mercado
funcione de forma natural como
mencionamos antes el excedente total
inicial antes de impuestos era todo este
triángulo después de impuestos el
excedente total es éste trapezoide que
resulta de la suma de todas estas áreas
lo que se pierde es esta área que está
aquí y esa es la pérdida irrecuperable
de eficiencia entonces de más w es igual
a la pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia
y con eso terminamos nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo